姐还跟我都非常喜欢你的，
因为他现在就是要找到一个结婚对象嘛，
他跟我说要结婚，
我有点不太觉得不太合适，
但是我也不知道要怎么跟他讲，
他能接受啊，
你给我描述一下他结婚对象是啥情况，
我们是贵州的嘛，
正好我跟我女儿都来上海了，
他认识这个男孩子差不多大概一年吧，
我们认识他，
然后也嗯同居，
他们差不多有半年吧，
然后我们也一起去吃过饭，
见过几次面，
但是我觉得说男孩子你说对我女儿上心嘛，
我们就一次，
呃，
一起出去过两次吃饭，
他从来没有主动买过一次单，
就是我们第一次见面的时候，
不是我生日嘛，
我女儿带她，
她说带她来了嘛，
然后她说她要跟她一起去，
那我说就来吧，
送了我的礼物，
可能就是我因为我喜欢跑步，
然后送了那个跑步，
她身上的那种药膏，
可能就100块钱左右，
然后我在想，
我说要是正常的哈，
要见家长的话，
应该不是这个样子的，
我对男方家的这个就是说是为人处事的药应该要稍微好一点点，
我感觉就是太抠门了，
我跟我女儿讲，
因为我儿现在26了嘛，
其实要是在我们贵州说谈婚恋爱这样是可以了，
那要是找到合适的话是可以的，
现次找这样抠门的男孩子的话，
我怕他以后会过得不好，
所以我叫她，
我说谈恋爱随便可以。
给谈，
但是结婚可能叫他不要着急，
但上两个礼拜给我打电话，
说他们想好了要结婚，
他问我要怎么样，
我说我没讲话，
然后他说你是不是好像不同意，
我说没有，
我我要笑话一下，
说我们见面了，
我说我再跟你聊一聊，
我一直不知道，
不知道要怎么跟他去讲这个问题，
我觉得你给我们的智慧，
所以说我想给你给我一点方法去跟他怎么去讲这个事，
这个男生是做什么工作的呢？
嗯嗯，
写文案的做男生的收入在一万五六左右，
我女儿在1万左右，
这个男生当时大学的时候学的什么专业呢？
说男的是大专，
我不知道我女儿是本科哦，
男生的父母是做什么的呢？
这个男孩子他在他家是浙江台州的，
然后他是跟他妈妈长大的，
他爸爸在他七八岁的时候就从家里消失了，
他跟我女儿讲的哈，
消失，
消失了以后就再也没有回来过，
然后七年回来了，
回来他在外面找了一个老婆的，
也生了一个儿子，
但是他回来的时候让这几十年呃，
赚的钱全部给他后面这个老婆跟儿子了，
自己就回来让他爷爷奶奶在那里，
然后说要来跟他这个前妻一起生活，
然后我跟我女儿说，
我说你们只是谈朋友，
她讲啥你听就可以了，
你不要去猜与他这个问题，
就觉得他这个家世有点乱，
我我家也是离异的，
但是我跟她那我我们也是我女儿七八岁的时候去朋友，
但是我一个人把我女儿带大了，
不像他这个像在他在自己的爸爸跟他妈还没有离婚，
虽然他他爸爸走出去那么多年都还没离婚，
你的女儿和她就是你觉得是你女儿爱她多一点，
还是她爱你女儿多一点，
绕开丈母娘这个身份，
作为朋友去观察他跟你女儿在一起，
呃，
生活的时候，
他对你女儿照顾吗，
心疼吗？
对你女儿好不好，
我就觉得他花钱这方面来说的话，
我感觉应该是我女儿爱她多一点。
因为我要是不是说给钱就爱你，
但是不给钱是一点都不爱你的，
因为从就是出现这种花费的话，
我觉得。
感觉好像不不够爱吧，
我我也觉得，
因为她比我女儿大八岁，
毕竟我女儿26，
她已经34了，
快35了，
可能是找不到更好的吧，
因为她家庭条件也不好，
他们在上海是不是啊，
也在这儿，
他们现在是同居在一起嘛，
同居在一起，
然后因为我女儿不烧饭，
嗯，
做其他家务，
但是他不会做饭，
做男孩子一个人开始也不太会烧，
但是为了他，
我说也在家里烧饭，
做个家务，
这去也做，
可能因为我女儿的爸爸是很非常懒的一个人，
她可能觉得找这个哈，
因为她以前也没有谈过恋爱，
真的也是，
她就觉得比她身边的男性认识的这个男性人来说哈，
就是我们老家那边的这个男性来说，
他说觉得这个已经很好了，
他说他那天跟我讲，
他说这个男的很有担当，
真的，
我都回避他这个话题我不讲，
我说见面了再跟他妈妈聊，
因为我不知道要怎么去跟他去讲这个，
他说假设闺女出嫁的话，
咱们这边能提供什么呢？
大概能嫁照能，
我可能给回去给他五六十万。
哦，
你姐姐你这边条件挺好的，
你是自己做生意吗？
我以前在上海开美容店，
现在没有开了，
现在行情不好嘛，
然后自己现在在一个公司上班，
一年也可以挣个三四十个这样的，
然后他那头这个有没有谈到彩礼啊，
彩礼男方能给多少啊，
他那天就打个电话问我，
他说问我有什么要求，
其实他家没有钱的，
他妈妈就是在他舅舅的工厂里面上班，
这样慢慢慢慢长大，
老家有个老债，
老大的话就是他以前呃跟他爸爸一起留下的，
他跟我女儿讲的就是要是在上海都买房子的话哈，
就是他们靠两个自己挣钱，
然后我是这样想的，
我说呃，
感觉可以的话，
要是买房子我会出一部分，
但是我我出多少钱，
但是我女儿要挣多少名额，
那份额，
我觉得这事你先别着急，
哎，
别先把这个工伤放出去，
你别说你嫁妆给五六十万这个事儿，
你这边你也哭穷，
你也说你没钱，
你也说你这个亏了，
被诈骗了或者干嘛的，
反正你就是没钱，
你别说你能给五六十万，
在你也没有钱的情况下，
他那边也没有钱的情况下，
俩要非要是想结婚的话，
可以拍婚纱照，
可以订婚宴，
可以办酒席，
都没有问题，
先别着急去领那个结婚证，
但是问题现在他不是他想领结婚证，
因为我们一直在外面啊，
他爸爸条件。
就很差，
他在那里，
他爸爸叫他回家去办酒，
说到酒店去，
钱都没有，
说到农村去办，
他也不愿意，
你就记住一点，
你记天就哭穷，
你就别出钱，
你只要不出钱，
他俩在办婚礼的过程当中，
他就他俩这那沙巴俩枣的，
他就知道有多难，
他就知道有就结个婚成个家多不容易，
他他是想，
嗯，
领个结婚证就算了，
但是我我的想法就是跟你一样的，
就是你办酒也好，
在一起生活也好，
但是我就不想让他领这个结婚证，
我觉得谈恋爱可以，
但是结婚很麻烦，
领了结婚证以后很会很麻烦，
既然他知道我有的，
他因为我我在老家有两套房子，
因为以后我们都不想回去了，
我在家里卖了一套房子，
是就是说卖了那套房子给他钱给他的，
你都没明白我的意思，
我的意思啊，
我知道啊，
你你讲的呀，
就是我给我战略战术，
战略战术，
你如果上来给他五六十万的话，
他俩日子过的那个贼美，
他就感受不到一个又又抠又那个什么的男的有多那个啥，
他就会觉得他愿意多付出点钱，
因为你给了他那么多钱，
你知道吗？
你不给他钱的话，
他一个月就挣那些，
他得交房租是吧，
就这意思，
你要说拦能不能拦得住呢？
如果说能拦得住的话，
这个世界上哪有那么多恋爱脑啊，
哪有那么多前仆后继去上当受骗的，
拦不住你唯一能。
做的就是当有一天她后悔的时候，
你能给她兜底，
你能养得活她，
万一她哪天咔嚓生个孩子了，
你也能养得活他们娘俩，
你唯一能做的是这个拦是很难拦得住的，
尤其是像你女儿这种缺乏父爱的，
他一旦认出了一个男的，
替代了他父爱这个角色的话，
你再说这个男的不好，
他还跟你急眼，
他跟你就成仇人了啊，
对的对的，
所以我我一说一直没有讲，
他跟他谈的时候，
他讲他家庭环境的时候，
我马上就觉得一路出去几次以后，
我都觉得说男的不行，
然后他觉得就是男的会会烧饭了，
然后又理解他了，
怎么样怎么样，
我都我我我都不讲，
因为他们吃菜啊，
买吃菜买肉啊，
我都经常给他们买，
他送过去，
但其实女孩子很喜欢他嘛，
给我们送这么多东西，
我说你，
然后这个概念是两码事，
我说因为你是我女儿，
我爱你，
我所以说我给你买，
我不是给她买，
她只是沾你的光。
但是我不当这个男孩子的面讲哈，
我是跟我女儿讲，
因为我从来没有说这个男子不好，
然后他认为我也很喜欢这个男孩子，
其实不是，
我只是不想让他第一次谈恋爱就说我父母是父母讲妻讲他不好，
让他以前都讲她不结婚了，
但是呃，
一谈一个恋爱就不再讲了，
就没多久就要结婚了，
我感觉你应该很坦诚的告诉你的女儿，
很坦诚的告诉他，
你觉得这个这个人对，
以你女儿的这样一个条件的话，
她能找到更好的，
然后你觉得这个她现在找的这个男朋友太抠门了，
尤其是发现女儿的妈妈还有点经济实力的时候，
她可能更更是通过对你女儿好的这种方式来从你女儿身上榨取一些利益，
觉得你还是要跟你女儿坦诚的去沟通一下，
我觉得这个时间两个礼拜我都不怎么睡得着，
因为我就觉得她有点僵虑，
因为我这婚姻不好，
我不想让我的孩子婚姻也不好，
我觉得沟通这事也是要讲策略的，
就是首先妈妈会支持你的决定，
如果你最终决定要嫁给他的话，
我会尊重你，
因为你是一个独立的，
一个成熟的一个人，
但是我会把我自己的态度摆在这里，
我认为你能找到更好的，
而且我认为他没有那么爱你，
我认为他如果足够爱你的话，
就应该重视你的这个亲人，
对吧，
如果足够爱你的话，
他应该要顾及到就是你的面子，
比如说啊，
第一次跟我们吃饭的时候，
他是不是应该。
主动去买单呀，
这个是不是应该最起码的对见女方长辈，
见女方家长的一种尊重啊，
应该是男方去挑选比较合适的餐厅，
男方去点菜，
男方去点对吧，
要顾及一下女方的这个口味，
女方妈妈的口味，
男方付账，
我觉得这个事情是在情理之中的呀，
不，
这意思就是你坦率的啊，
嗯，
坦率的告诉他，
但是你如果决定了要跟他结婚的话，
我也尊重你啊，
但是我这边能做的就是给你兜底，
万一哪一天啊，
假设说你们过不好，
你呃呃，
跟他分手了之后啊，
妈妈可以给你兜底，
但是在这个结婚的过程当中，
你们自己去安排，
你们想在哪里接，
想怎么接，
想办什么样的婚礼，
我都尊重你们，
你看好你的钱袋子就完事儿了，
嗯，
好的好的，
谢谢你啊，
真的，
这非常感谢，
然后再跟你的女儿说，
什么时候你，
呃，
确信确信你觉得这个男生他可以成为一个好爸爸，
一个对孩子负责任的爸爸，
你再考虑生孩子这个问题，
好的好的，
嗯，
好嗯好，
谢谢你啊，
天，
嗯，
我觉得啊，
如果这个男孩是一个20出头的，
没有经验的这样一个愣头青，
没有社会经验的这样一个愣头青，
可能对吧，
多多少少你还觉得他年轻，
他不懂事儿，
但如果这个男生他已经34岁了，
34岁在这个社会上，
我觉得不管怎么样。
那他应该要懂一些人情世故吧，
你第一次跟女孩的家长在一起吃饭是吧？
第一次女孩的家长来这边看你们，
我觉得这个是不是咱们已经成为一个普遍的一个共识了，
我们作为想要娶人家的女儿，
想要娶人家的闺女，
你是不是得上杆子，
你是不是得献殷勤，
你是不是得在尽力在丈母娘面前去表现你的实力，
表现你对她女儿有多好，
有多在乎，
这个才是一个正常的情理，
是吧？